aérien de jour comme de nuit
les militaires français s'installent sur
la base de l'otan à constante ça les
températures sont négatives parfois il
neige
une partie des effectifs est constitué
de chasseurs alpins
ils se sont installés de manière
provisoire dans des tentes dortoirs
collectifs
mais aussi caserne improvisé avec une
partie armurerie
en moins de 10 jours 500 soldats
français vont trouver place ici une
installation sommaire mais efficace
on était d' alerte mais comment elle a
été déclenchée ça a été la surprise et
et après ça a déroulé selon le blanc qui
a été prévu pour nous les véhicules
aussi sont arrivés plusieurs dizaines à
bord de grands avions de transport
ils sont stationnés non loin des pistes
le sergent-chef geoffrey les recense à
20 qu'il soit affecté aux différentes
missions de la logistique je combats la
ja du gbc 180 pour du transport de
personnel du ravitaillement ration en
haut vous avez du vab donc du véhicule
de l'avant blindé pareil du vab
différents types de vins de différentes
versions la roumanie est en première
ligne elle partage avec l'ukraine 650 km
de frontières qui sont devenus
stratégique dans le conflit en cours
pour les habitants de constantes ça la
guerre se rapprochent certes mais les
roumains se sont protégés je ne panique
pas personne ne sait ce que veut
vraiment poutine ses ambitions et ses
projets je pense que c'est comme un jeu
de poker on vit des temps dangereux mais
on est dans le temps on est protégé
des milliers de soldats qui ont avant
tout un rôle dissuasif pour que quoi
qu'il arrive de l'autre côté de la
frontière en ukraine le conflit ne
déborde pas sur l'europe centrale